basket hier soir c'était la grande
première finalement pour camille combal
clé en prime time avec qui veut garder
millions je vous rappelle qu'il a
remplacé évidemment jean pierre foucault
c'est ainsi une première qui on va le
dire qui est compliqué qui vont manquer
fiasco alors voilà 5 millions 2,4 le
lancement de nouvelles levées là on
tombe à 2 millions neuf cent ses nerfs
fois crémant il peut gagner des millions
étaient aussi diffusée un jeudi il
remplaçait une série qui cartonne et la
section de recherches est effectivement
sur les parts d'audience liée aux femmes
responsables des achats ce qui est le
plus important pour tf1 ils sont 1 13%
et kate qui est extrêmement faible de
l'histoire pour l'histoire du jeu donc à
voir sur la durée
concernant l'avenir de qui veut gagner
mignon parce que des émissions sont en
cours de tournage pour une quotidienne
qui sera diffusé normalement pendant
l'été aux alentours de 18h15 donc il a
absolument pas porter le programme et il
a par secteur mais voilà c'est clair
c'était un programme qui demande à
janvier quand même un homme abattu un
bon ami parle doucement qui sait jouer
avec la dramaturgie ce que vous faites
parfaitement vous le faisiez sur un
contre sens il ya un ou deux animateurs
qui sont capables de le faire
il a [ __ ] en l'air le plus endetté et
en plus à un moment donné il arrive à
dire
gillou c'était bon à la cantoche qu'en
mai lorsque l'on appuie le programme et
il aurait vu en plus si vous voulez
faire un événement parce
qu'effectivement il ya ce problème
et moi j'ai beaucoup travaillé entre
autre et là sur les décès vous aviez à
l'époque une semaine pour faire un
hommage à serge ans maintenant à cause
d'internet à cause des chaînes
d'information mercredi 48 heures après
ça n'est plus un événement
il aurait déjà dû le faire en direct ça
c'était il ya eu des moments et après 48
heures vous ne trouverez plus votre
audience c'est fini alors on a évoqué le
style de camille combal
on vous a fait un petit récap était hier
soir sur tf1 c'est parti
bienvenue dans qui veut gagner des
millions
nous accueillons tout de suite a dit
pierre coudrais et harry roselmack
merci le pas
je me sens par inspirez vous voulez mon
avis ça lui joue c'est camille combal on
est sur le plateau de qui veut gagner
des millions
voilà un bon soir qu'elle va pas super
alors il y avait quoi comme menu à la
cantoche ce soir voici ce que je pense
[Musique]
et maman je donne mon avis à albert
congrès et harry roselmack soirée à tous
merci
c'est vrai que comme ça c'est
visuellement gênante énorme entre le
contexte dramatique et la décontraction
qui par ailleurs basse très bien parfois
chez combal que là il n'avait pas le
droit d'afficher donc en fait
effectivement on avait besoin d'un
bonhomme on avait peut-être besoin que
ce soir à tf1 qu est ce qu ils fassent
rappelle jean pierre foucault que ça
devienne un truc exceptionnel et que le
mec qui soit là qu'ils fassent pas des
vannes à tout bout de champ en dix ans
bon bah du coup je vais quand même
imposé mon style combal qui est très
sympa par ailleurs mais qui n'avait rien
à faire là mais hier soir il rêvait
parce qu'il faut un peu relativiser
évidemment pour camille combal qui a
fait huit ans avec cyril forcément au
contact de quelqu'un qui tarde peut
quitter un peu 100 m il prit prend des
mimiques
est ce que finalement si il est pas tout
le temps un peu bas à la route de selena
serré l'année donc quand il est
interrogé si on sait news avec jean
pierre elkabbach et cela passe c'est ce
que je disais déjà au moment de danse
avec les stars
et parfois on me le reprocher camille
combal n'a pas les toffes camille combal
encerclé star civique au combat c'est un
super chroniqueur c'est pas magnifique
heures pour endosser ce rôle il restera
éternellement l'élève d'hanouna et les
moins bons clos m donc on a l'impression
de voir à cyril mais un mauvais cyril ça
ne passe pas il n'a pas l'étoffé pour
supporter un tel programme c'est une
erreur de casting
je sais que certains pensent que je me
trompe je les aime beaucoup mais il n'a
pas l'étoffé sur les réseaux c'était
vraiment clairement les oilers
saint géry c'est une physionomie il n'a
pas de faire se mêlent étaient propres
il n'a pas de style il n'a pas de
griffin a pas de pattes voilà le verdict
est là non mais sérieux là dessus c'est
tf1 qui lui fait du mal parce que lui
donnait ce programme c'est pas le
permettre de prendre toutes censées lui
et il a voulu forcer l'exploit par
l'état s'il te plaît dans ce programme
là il est assis déjà il doit avoir un
rôle d'homme qui qui posent des
questions qui fait passer du suspense
c'est pas du tout mon truc
oui il est là pour sautiller pour faire
des blagues il était super dans danse
avec les stars war vi novartis mans on a
envie de le voir sur des missions des
déguisements masques est singer pourquoi
pas mais pas là d'ssus lettres sur leurs
pas c'est pas une erreur de casting
c'est une erreur d'ambiance il n'était
pas dans la bonne ambiance hier soir
voilà mais si vous prenez si vous prenez
la première sans jean pierre foucault la
première émission qui l'animé il était
excellent on aimerait d'ailleurs eu mais
de là à dire que c'est pas un amateur et
là aussi ça mettra les tops se mettent à
l'époque d'un animateur et à mon âge
d'une corde donc dix ans il est du
niveau 2 pour banshee progrès parce que
c'est un ami
c'est pas non je vais vous dire la
vérité ça six monnaies je suis
extrêmement n'est pas bon dit une amie
d'arthur en face qui lui a pas non plus
face alors attaché le casting juste
alors je vous dis une chose c'est vrai
que pour pour camille se retrouver face
à des grosses pointures notamment face à
arthur face à boccolini qui sont pour le
coup une chaîne et que tu as deux un
monument de la chaîne excusez moi il y
avait il y avait vraiment il y avait un
gros décalage est effectivement et
y'avait excusez moi on a senti un
malaise est bien sûr déjà de blagues et
avec arthur c'était un peu comme ça
regardez qu'elle était vulnérable en fut
largement celle le couple princier qui a
fait longtemps que les a pas vu kate
c'est vrai qu'à changer tout à fait le
duo on s'en faire l'accolade
mais il n'était pas du tout rentrer à
sakété un an ouais là les gens bien
élevés la crim
ça ça concerne les personnes âgées la
qibla tu es jeune mais vous savez
comment on va déjà redoublé la soie bah
c'est pas monde et d'europe 1 ça va vite
là non moi je veux pas faire d'histoires
je suis un peu d'accord 88 elle est
forte c'est pour zéro euro
le souviens je me souviens on avait
passé sa pour tes 30 ans tu fais pas de
loin peut soit là qu'il fait venir
terminer la soirée qu'une médaille n'a
pas besoin de rigoler il faut tenir une
dramaturgie des labos n'est ainsi pas du
tout mais non ça passe et on part il a
rigolé quand vous sortez pas de la
journée des martyrs des deux pas des
masses mais en même temps il est pile
excusez moi il n'est pas là pour ça il
est invité il ya un animateur à lui de
faire le job franchement oui
alors franchement on n'a pas le droit de
parler
yahia dans le regard d'arthur un petit
côté ben vas-y fais ton métier montrez
moi le meilleur comment je suis pas
persuadé carte joker est fatale recevrez
ferrer qui est plat soit inversée au
fond de lui même réponse mais bon c'est
voilà et c'est vrai que le sport c'est
vrai que pour tf1 il ya se pose le choix
ils ont pris un animateur il faut il
faut l'imposer
il impose sa démission qui existait
depuis très longtemps qu'ils étaient
quand même relativement user user voilà
avoir fêté à l'aube à ses bâtons pelles
à leur tour pour la route et à la roue
tourne t on va dire oui et après dans le
positionnement de l'animateur s'était
pas vraiment le sentiment qu'il est dans
une pièce de il est dans une quête est
en fait ils ne cherchent ils pensent
canton de vaud pour ça nous lâche je
vous dis je vous dirai qui tu es tout le
temps et les gens sur les réseaux c'est
ce qu'il dit oui et a été de 2 2 à
l'aller il ya une filiation est
malheureusement quand on fait huit ans
avec quelqu'un croyez-moi quand on fait
huit ans à côté de quelqu'un qui est
forcément un peu vos billets des votes m
forcément on prend des habitudes on
prend des tickets à mon avis pour lui
l'important c'était de sortir de cette
image là est d'arriver à faire son style
à lui qui pour l'instant à mon avis n'a
pas trouvé moi je suis convaincu qu'avec
les anonymes c'est beaucoup plus facile
pour camille qui va plus prendre sa
place même si je le redis pour moi c'est
pas du tout le bon casting d'avoir
camille combal sur ce genre
reste qu'en vont être compliqués s'il a
fait toute l'animation comme ça et que
ça en boîte serait conclu s'il arrête
moi qui adore qui veut gagner des
millions fait pas du tout bien le
regarder cia il ya plus de ramat urgent
il ya plus rien après où elle seule un
terrain autre problème après ils passent
après foucault excusez-moi foucault
c'est le problème
ah oui le maître incontesté en tout cas
des jeux il est très très bon et
dangereux là il était à mon avis
indissociables beaucoup de réactions sur
les réseaux étaient tous et jean-pierre
le retour des européens bien sûr ils
sont le remède pour tenter de sauver
l'émission y'a pas d'autre solution
benjamin vous avez d'excellentes de la
télé vous le savez très bien tous cas
s'il avait envie de mettre camille
combat âpre et tendre présentation et
miss france sur les prochaines je pense
que c'est terminé c'est mais c'est pas
du tout de cette nature chaque fois et
on a peut-être envie d'enterrer merlus
comme jean-pierre il a réussi à faire
venir les miss france à marseille on va
revenir sur sur arthur qui était donc
dans l'émission hier qui a décidé à la
fin de sa partie de donner de l'argent
regardez 72000 c'est une belle somme
c'est à vous de décider
moi j'ai une proposition jeu
[Musique]
oui
on s'arrête
bon ben on s'arrête
mais comme j'aime pas le chiffre rond je
rajoute la différence pour arriver à 100
me
[Applaudissements]
il n'y a pas de regrets
super bien joué on arrive à 100 donc on
arrête là c'est votre dernier mot c'est
votre dernier mot et c'est très très
bien joué
c'est pourquoi j'ai envie de c'est lui
le jugement cette région alors moi ce
que j'aime avec tf1 ce qu'on avait fait
par exemple au csii art en 2012 je crois
la visibilité des associations dans les
médias parce que les associations disait
qu'elle n'était jamais vu dans les
médias et c'est la chaîne qui met le
plus en avant les associations
pourquoi je dis ça c'est parce qu'ils
auraient dû justement avec des gestes
comme celui là ne pas donner ne plus
donner à notre dame
puisque tout le monde a déjà surenchéri
sur notre dame veilleurs guerre contre
les pats exactement exactement les
pompiers ou encore regarder cette
identité pour versés à des associations
aujourd'hui qu'ils ont honte ils rient
blement besoin est juste le mans pau
contre balancer le supporte pas ce débat
sur le fait
bon bref non mais en vendée par le geste
d'arthur saluer jean louis franchement
oui j'ai rien à me revoir ce qu'on a
c'est bien que lui mais me dit on arrête
là je mets jusqu'à 100000 c'est un beau
geste de quelqu'un qui peut se le
permettre mais franchement c'est un beau
job de sa luge est
et là pour le coup assez voilà vos biens
tels que la séquence n'était pas
forcément bien bien amiens d'accord
alors oui parce que je trouve que ça met
mal à l'aise
laurence boccolini il ya une gêne à son
niveau et le chef d' arthur il est très
grand et très noble mais elle du coup ça
la mer qui bat manon parce qu'il faut
rappeler aux gens que c'est un capitaine
d'industrie animateurs ils jouent pas
dans la même cour à mon ami
financièrement ces voix là mais c'est
vrai mais en revanche bien évidemment
c'est un grand monsieur labertit la
femmelle et j'ai pas pu donner alors en
tout cas cet effet ils ont vas pas me
saluer le geste